Salut à vous peuple des internet. Enfin on se retrouve d'une manière un petit peu intime sur cette chaîne, juste vous et moi.
Avant de commencer à parler de ces 25 émotions cachées, vous aurez remarqué deux choses : déjà c'est pas ma caméra parce que la mienne vient
de se casser ce matin.
La légria, oui celle qui ne se fait plus et qui ne se vend plus. Je suis très heureux.
J'ai donc emprunté celle-ci pour aujourd'hui et puis je vais voir comment je vais faire pour la suite. Mais tous les changements que vous voyez au niveau
de la lumière, ça c'est autre chose.
Je viens de faire récemment une vidéo avec la chaîne de Vini Vidi Filmi où Bruno a pris le temps de me coacher sur la lumière de
m'apprendre à utiliser des lumières avec un petit budget. Le lien de cette vidéo sera dans la description, si vous voulez en voir plus
je vous recommande parce que je suis en train de comprendre plein de choses et ça va être cool pour l'évolution de cette chaîne.
Mais c'est parfait ! Si le voisin en profitait pour faire des travaux ! Nous sommes très heureux de ça ! Et également quelques secondes avant de commencer je
vous rappelle que les ventes pour les billets de l'Olympia sont en place. Je viens de filmer un
spectacle l'autre jour, je vais pouvoir vous faire voir un petit peu ce qu'il y a dans ce spectacle.
En tout cas, c'est un projet commun entre vous et moi donc n'hésitez pas à réserver ou à prendre des places pour Noël. Parce qu'en
plus de sélectionner les meilleures places pour le spectacle, ça permet, en même temps, moi d'imaginer des choses plus conséquentes en fonction du nombre de
personnes qui réservent. Et à chaque réservation de place justement, je
vis une émotion particulière. Mais parfois quand on vit une émotion, comme la joie par exemple, comme dans la dernière vidéo les émotions qu'on
s'amusait à jouer avec Super Konnard et Céline H,
on peut trouver que le mot qui est issu de cette émotion en elle-même est limitant. Autant c'est pratique dans les micro-expressions
d'avoir une émotion brute et une espèce de case dans lesquelles on peut les ranger, et donc les détecter,
autant on aimerait avoir une palette de mots un peu plus complexes pour définir une émotion particulière.
Eh bien, c'est exactement ce que s'est dit l'écrivain John Koenig dans son
dictionnaire des chagrins obscurs...
[bruits de travaux]
Faut arrêter les travaux, faut aller manger à un moment donné. Je suis désolé pour le bruit, je suis obligé de faire cette vidéo maintenant sinon
elle ne pourra pas sortir vendredi.
Ce que j'étais en train de vous dire, l'écrivain John Koenig, qui a écrit le dictionnaire des chagrins obscurs,
s'est posé le même constat et la même question. Il a, à ce titre,
créé des mots pour des émotions particulières qui existent mais qui ne peuvent pas être
nominatives. J'ai trouvé ça hyper intéressant de vous en parler parce qu'en plus je trouve que les mots
correspondent un petit peu à cette réalité là. Par exemple, comme sentiment, il a inventé l'anecdoche
l'anecdoche.
L'anecdoche, pour lui, c'est ce que tu ressens dans une conversation où tout le monde parle et personne ne s'écoute. Un sentiment d'anecdoche.
J'aime bien l'idée de ce mot et j'aime bien ce mot, je vais vous en donner comme ça une petite quinzaine. Une ellipisim,
c'est le sentiment que l'on ressent, le sentiment de tristesse, quand on se rend compte qu'on ne connaîtra jamais la fin d'une histoire.
Le zenosyne, c'est le sentiment que tout va de plus en plus vite.
L'exulansis, on n'a pas un peu l'impression d'être dans Harry Potter ? Alors, l'exulansis, c'est le sentiment d'essayer de
prendre fin à une conversation, de fermer une conversation, de la terminer, parce que personne ne comprend ce que vous êtes en train de dire.
Ce qui est peut être exactement ce qui est en train de se passer, là, entre nous. Le chrysalisme,
alors le chrysalisme, j'aime bien ce mot parce que j'aime bien le sentiment qu'il décrit.
C'est le sentiment que tu as quand tu es chez toi, dans ta maison, alors que dehors il pleut
énormément, il tombe des cordes, y a de l'orage, ou il neige.
Enfin, ou il fait être vraiment un temps dégueulasse, mais que toi tu es tranquille, en sécurité, au sec et au chaud dans ta maison.
L'onisme,  rien à voir avec l'onanisme, c'est pas du tout pareil. L'onisme c'est un sentiment de frustration d'être
coincé dans un corps, dans un lieu, en faisant qu'une seule chose à la fois. C'est le sentiment comme ça
restrictif qu'on ressent, l'onisme. Le rubatosis, rien à voir avec une maladie, non, le rubatosis c'est le
sentiment quand on vient de prendre conscience de chaque battement de son coeur. Vous savez quand on l'entend, qu'on le ressent, on est focus dessus qu'on
se rend compte que ça fonctionne. Eh bien, c'est un petit rubatosis que tu ressens en ce moment là.
Le vellichor, alors le vellichor, c'est un sentiment a
priori non défini
mais c'est la chose que l'on ressent quand on voit des vieux livres usés. Il a mis un nom sur ce sentiment là le vellichor.
Je trouvais ça très intéressant de voir quelqu'un qui, avec son imagination, a mis des mots sur des sentiments qu'on n'avait pas
déterminés forcément, qui sont plus des sensations
mêlées à des émotions. Et parfois, quand on met un mot sur un sentiment ou sur une pensée particulière ça prend sens
différemment. Je vous mets un lien vers son livre dans la description, je vous mets aussi un lien vers une conférence Ted qu'il avait faite
et qui est très inspirante. Moi il y a quelques temps de ça, quelques mois même, j'avais fait une vidéo en fait sur
l'impact du mot sur la pensée. C'est si on change un mot par un autre, c'est utilisé par exemple en communication et en politique,
alors la pensée est construite différemment. Je vous mets un lien vers cette vidéo, si vous l'avez pas vue je vous la recommande.
Dans les commentaires vous pouvez m'imaginer vous aussi un mot correspondant à une émotion. Faites le vraiment, jouez le jeu.
J'essaierai d'en trouver un aussi, je mettrai moi aussi un truc ou deux comme ça dans les commentaires de
d'émotions que je serais capable d'inventer. Donc vous prenez une situation,
vous analysez l'émotion que vous ressentez et vous mettez un nom à ça, vous lui donnez un nom et vous mettez dans les commentaires. N'oubliez pas de
liker si ce n'est pas encore fait, de vous abonner à la chaîne évidemment, parce que le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Mais ça, c'était l'année dernière donc à mardi.
Ciao !
Alors si c'est pas encore fait, tu peux aussi t'abonner à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois, voilà, juste ici, c'est ce petit rond là. Ca marche depuis la tablette, le téléphone
c'est extrêmement pratique ! Il n'y a plus de raison d'attendre.
Allez-y, abonnez vous, c'est cool !